ladies and gentlemen go wild the Genesee
the pressure is on at season 15 of So
You Think You Can Dance winds down and
we gear up to crown a new winner I'm
just so grateful to be standing here as
America's top 4 and hopefully America's
favorite dancer I felt really strong
about this performance we're just gonna
see how this whole underdog comeback
gonna work out this experience has been
the best experience of my whole life I
just having fun and embracing every
single last moment I have there was a
fire in your eyes that reminded me of
Jennifer Lopez you got a pretty nice
comparison tonight Jennifer Lopez from
the blocks do you have a favorite memory
as this season winds down honestly
meeting my partner meeting genesee
definitely up there because that makes
me better as a person and as a dancer
but you know meeting such an incredible
person like Jenna see it was one of the
highlights for sure in New York I really
asked a black artists you have audition
you have put yourself out there time and
time again don't like next year do you
need a little more time what gave you
the motivation to keep fighting for this
when a lot of people would be like I'm
going home you know it was actually my
mom I sat down at the kitchen counter
with her and she was just like when your
mom and a couple of years you're gonna
look back and wish because I did not
want to do it I was like no mom I don't
want it yeah I'm over it I'm done being
rejected I had to just kind of give
myself a little bit of confidence
because my confidence is so well
laughter and I said but you know what
I'm great and I've already experienced
the worst so let's do it again
for 18 year-old finalist Hanalei
she's already walking away a winner My
partner is Javon and it was really fun
dancing with him and we're actually
dating now to me about the decision to
reveal that tonight I don't know I just
feel writer the producer that were
talking to me about it and they're like
why not it was cool are gonna be Matlin
saying what does his support mean to you
throughout this entire experience
he's been at every live show which is so
amazing and I just love having him here
yeah what is it you adore about him so
much he's so cute your roommate is
Hanalei did you know that she had this
boyfriend I see him ever so cute so
sweet squeeze so cute I'm not shocked by
that because I got I got a white pant is
like another language of love every
single week and he's been in different
locations in the studio audience I just
seasoned he's definitely gonna try out
next year because he is like at all the
shows up he's committed to being here
you didn't know I've been here and he
wants to learn every little nugget you
know I notice real motive was I know I
do hope he comes back and tries out
because she can come and root for him
let you go she could be his all-star you
never know you never know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]